hello chess fans i'm back with more news
about the new
strongest chess engine ever stockfish
new
this engine combines the neural network
approach of alpha zero and leela chess
zero
with the brute force computing of the
latest versions of stockfish
now in our last video we mentioned that
this engine was gearing up for a 200
game match against leela chess zero
that match has been completed and
it got absolutely destroyed just
absolutely massacred
110.5 to 89.5
however the developers then reached out
and said whoa whoa whoa
things are not optimally configured here
we can improve this performance with
better configurations
they've sent updated instructions and
now
stockfish new is contesting a 600 game
match
with leela chess0 and the latest version
of stockfish
and it is winning in this video we are
going to look
at one of the games where stock fish new
played
leela chessero and it did not get
destroyed instead
it won a fine attacking game in the
style of the great romantic masters
to keep things exciting in the chess.com
computer chess
championship the engines are given
opening books to play
with tons of dynamic and gambit
positions
this game for example opens up with e4
e5 bishop c4
and pawn to f5 this is the calabresi
counter gambit in response to the
bishop's opening
evidently now both engines will have to
play this position with white
and with black to keep things fair
stockfish new has white this time around
and it pushes forward with d4
it is sensing opportunity because of the
push f5 which softens the light squares
and white is already in position to try
and exploit that
d4 is trying to open as many lines as
possible
the classic response to such a move as
pawn to f5
now here we see captures on d4 and
knight to h3
a strong but unintuitive move as humans
we are taught from a young age
not to put our knights on the edge of
the board because they will lack
mobility
but in this case what matters is that
white is ready to castle
and the knight has developed without
blocking queen to h5
check for example if captures on e4
queen to h5 check
g6 queen to e5 wins the rook on h8 and
wins the game
this is a trap that beginners regularly
fall into
so after knight h3 we see knight to f6
and now
e5 and knight g4 we can already pause
and assess the difficulties that lila is
trying to overcome in this position
for example how do you castle
the answer you do not get to castle this
bishop on c4 is
too strong and there's not going to be
any chance for lilith castle in this
game
also this pawn here on e5 it is a
monster
it is influencing the middle of the
board in a tremendous way
making it very difficult for black to
develop the minor pieces and to
coordinate them
it is also stopping d6 or d5 because
captures will open up the e file and
bring a huge attack against black's king
on e8
so in this position the problems for
black may
already be insurmountable so we see
castles
in this position if knight takes then
rookie 1 and f4 will win the knight
so we see knight c6 rookie 1 bishop e7
and now that the e file has been closed
black is ready to capture on e5
we see stockfish new anticipate that and
pull the loose bishop back to b3
knight takes e5 and now knight d2 pawn
to a5
thinking about a4 trying to
inconvenience that bishop
and knight f3 d6 a4 for white stopping
a4 from black
and in this position lila is already
looking for a move and struggling to
find it
it plays the move king to f8 a very sad
move
the king steps off of the open e file
but it is not that much safer on f8
also this rook on h8 is wondering how
it's ever going to get
into the game spoiler alert it is not
it is going to die on that square after
king to f8 i think the ball is
firmly firmly in white's court so king
f8 knight takes d4 knight takes d4 queen
takes d4 bishop f6
a cheap threat to win the queen that any
computer is going to immediately stop
queen to e3
c6 bishop d2 h6 and rook a to d1
now in this position i think white
is sitting pretty look at all these
pieces
everything is on its optimal square
pretty much
everything is centralized has access to
good squares
has access to strong targets
the king on g1 totally totally safe
the opposite is true for black
especially the black rooks in the corner
are
really struggling to get active and the
black king on f8 does not feel safe
at all so in this position after rook a
to d1
we see pawn to g5 queen g3 and pawn to
f4
i'm really struggling to explain g5 and
f4 but i guess when you don't have
anything better to do you might as well
push your pawns
and now we get knight takes f4 a
beautiful sacrifice of the knight
for two pawns after pawn takes we get
bishop takes f4
now there's a threat here to capture on
e5 and win material because of the pin
on the d-file so queen to e7
now i'm singing the praises of the
sacrifice of the knight for two pawns
but as a human it is not easy to see how
to break through
in this position in fact it looks like
black may be close to finishing
development
coordinating the position and you could
be left with nothing
in fact there is only one winning move
in this position
i encourage you to pause your video and
try to figure out what it is
well to be honest that was kind of a
trick question because i don't expect
anyone literally anyone watching this
video
unless you're a computer engine yourself
to find the winning move
the winning move is pawn to h3
only winning move why is that the only
winning move
first let's consider the alternatives in
this position
you want to try and break through
tactically but it turns out your back
rank is weak
if rook takes d6 queen takes d6
in this position capturing e5 with the
rook either now or later
is going to open up your back rank and
you are going to get mated
you have basically the same problems
after rook takes e5
rook takes e5 bishop takes e5
and now a beautiful idea rook takes d6
and it turns out though that queen takes
d6 bishop takes
and queen d1 you have exposed your back
rank again
an alternative that is much better but
is not winning is bishop
takes h6 check if you found this move i
kind of feel like you deserve full
credit because
h3 was too insane to find and this is
the second best move
after bishop takes h6 rook takes you
have queen g8
the problem is that after bishop takes
h6 king e8
there's not a finishing blow it looks
like pawn to f4 might do the job
you've got a pin here on the e file but
in this position
there is bishop to h4 and you're
skewered
and this position is insanely insanely
messy but you're not winning
so after queen to e7 it is this move
pawn to h3
and it turns out that with the back rank
covered there is no defense to rook
takes d6
or rook takes e5 crushing sacrificial
ideas
so after pawn to h3 there was nothing
better for leela so once again it
decided to push a pawn and it played
pawn to h5
and in this position you can win with
either rook takes d6 or rook takes e5
and stockfish new decides on rook takes
e5
now first let's consider d takes e5 in
this position with the d
file open you're able to go back to your
idea bishop h6 check
because king e8 will not save the day in
this case because of queen g6
and umate so after bishop h6
you can consider rook takes h6 and queen
g8 we've already seen this mate
and you can also consider the more
resilient bishop g7
but in this position after bishop g7
there is rook to d8
and you force mate this is a beautiful
decoy sacrifice
queen takes queen takes king over and
queen f7
and mate beautiful beautiful stuff
so after rook takes e5 instead of
opening the d file we see bishop takes
e5
in another great sacrifice rook takes
d6 a beautiful double sacrifice of the
rooks
first on e5 and then on d6 first off if
bishop takes d6
then bishop takes d6 pins and wins the
queen
and if you have queen takes d6 then
there is bishop takes e5
the check on d1 is no longer mate and
after king h2
there is no way to save this rook thanks
to ideas of queen g8 and queen g7
once the rook falls white's attack will
also be overwhelming
so after bishop takes e5 rook takes d6
in this position we see bishop takes f4
and you still need good strong moves to
finish this game off
in this position there's queen takes f4
check and there are two king moves you
can consider here
first off if king g7
then we have a sequence of queen checks
queen d4 check
king h7 queen d3 check the queen goes
into g6
and now after king f8 another beautiful
rook sacrifice
rook to d8 decoying the queen away so
that you can mate with queen f7
after queen takes f4 check therefore the
king goes to e8
king eight and bishop f7 check you're
still down a rook and you're sacrificing
more material
queen takes and queen e5 check you're
hitting the king and the rook here
if king goes to f8 then queen takes h8
wins right away
if king up then there's mate and if the
queen chooses to block after queen takes
h8
then you simply have well honestly
multiple moves but
this will win the queen here in fact you
actually can force mate with queen f6
and queen f7 and rook to d8 so
after bishop f7 and then queen takes and
queen e5 check we see bishop e6
rook takes and still we're down a rook
but the king must go to d7 to avoid this
rook falling with check
and in this position you have queen d6
check king back
and rook to e7 you're threatening the
queen
and you're threatening mate here on c7
so the queen must give itself up
and after queen takes white is totally
winning
now materially white has a queen and two
pawns which is stronger than two rooks
but not by a lot
but what really matters is that both
rooks are still in their starting
squares
and this king is still exposed therefore
there's really no hope for black
we're going to zip through the rest of
the moves white is going to pick off
some pawns
and start advancing the white pawns as
well
we see some maneuvering to get the queen
to an optimal square
and what i really like here is after the
capture on c2
in this position queen b5 check is a
nice
accurate move that picks up a rook with
a fork next turn no matter what
if you go to the a file there is queen
to a4 check and this rook falls
if you go to c8 there is queen to f5
check and this rook falls again
but after king c7 in the game it's the
rook on h8 that falls instead
i did give you a spoiler and tell you
that the rook would fall on the
on h8 without ever getting to move so
queen takes h8
and now i'm going to zip through the
rest of the moves it's not going to take
long for white to force mate here we're
going to make a second queen
and then the king is going to be very
quickly mated here
after queen to e4 a beautiful game and a
beautiful finish
i hope that you enjoyed this game if you
want to see more games like it go to
chess.com
ccc short for computer chess
championship
and you can watch the match that is
currently in progress
also i encourage you to check out the
video with the previous game which is
also beautiful
in different ways